And for
[Silence]
This narration in the first chapter of
continuing where we left off. The ninth
narration is on the authority of Bakari
Bakari.
He narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
if two Muslims meet one another with
their swords meet one another with their
swords meaning in battle meet one
another to fight with their swords.
So here we have two things. Number one
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam describes them as Muslims
but then he says with their swords and
swords here articulates
intention.
What do we mean by that? Meaning that a
sword is not used to clobber someone.
It's not used to to harm someone. It's
used to kill. It's used to take life.
That's what it's designed for.
Therefore, the intention of these two is
clear. We wouldn't have in a Muslim
court a person use something a
sword in our modern time, a handgun,
something that is lethal, something that
is intended to kill.
And have them say, "Well, my intention
was just to scare the person. My
intention was this or that." Because as
we said before the principle that
taught us in
he says we mentioned this a couple days
ago. The principle is that intentions
are only
taken into consideration
in ambiguous situations.
Unclear situations. situations that
it could be this was what the person
intended or this is what the person
intended.
Not in a situation where
there's no a situation that is
explicit. Right? So for instance, let's
say a person
used a a a club, a billy club or a whip.
Let's say this is something that doesn't
usually kill, right? This is something
that is used to inflict pain but not
kill. Or let's say for instance in
modern times a taser,
a police officer using a taser for
instance. Well, sometimes people die
from that. It's not always. As a matter
of fact, it's very rare. Or for
instance, a bean bag, right? Not not at
you. I'm not shooting you. a bean bag,
right? A bean bag is used usually in a
shotgun and it's used in in you know
riot control and stuff that or
let's say tear gas that's used to
control crowds
things this, right? Can it take
life? Have these things taken life
before? Yes. The human body is very
frail. It can be very frail, right? And
just a person can survive 10
rounds from a machine gun by some
miracle, a person can also die from
falling off a foottool.
So if a person were to be tased, let's
say, and then the person died
and we were in a situation of judgment,
the the officer then comes and says, "I
didn't mean to kill the person. I only
meant to subdue them. You know, they
were acting crazy and I was just trying
to get the situation under control. In
this case, we would take into
consideration the intention. We take
into consideration his intention. Why?
Because it's ambiguous. It's ambiguous.
The act itself is ambiguous.
Right? But let's say a person uses a
handgun
or or they they use a club and and it
and it kills someone by accident or
uses a whip that causes a wound that
gets infected that later claims the
person's life. Right? This is what this
is ambiguous. We would take into
consideration the person's intention.
However, let's say a person uses a gun,
a handgun,
and let's say they shoot someone in the
leg. I said, "Well, I was just trying to
subdue them." A handgun is a lethal. Is
a It is used only with the intention to
kill, right? Anywhere you shoot in the
body, that's what it's for. It's
designed specifically for that. And so
the claim of my intention is not
relevant in this situation.
And so the same thing here in this kind
of narration he says
safe a safe a a sword is used to take
life. It's not used for just general
fighting or you know people having
small disputes or right when a person
uses a sword this sword has been
designed and crafted and honed and it's
also been trained with to take life. So
a person couldn't come and claim well I
didn't intend to kill him. No,
death is the is the expected result of
using a sword. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam articulates this this meaning
here in this narration. Why? Because he
says,
Muslim
[Silence]
safe.
And so he didn't say if two Muslims meet
one another with their swords drawn and
each intends to kill the other. He he
didn't say that. Why? Because a sword is
only used for that purpose.
Just a person could survive
a sword attack, right? Just you
could survive a handgun attack. But
that's not what it's designed for,
right? That's that's an outlier.
Most usually when you speak about
someone that's been struck with a sword,
you're speaking about a person who's
dead. You're speaking about someone
who's been shot with a gun. You're
speaking about someone who's dead,
right? And that's why in our language we
use shot
and dead synonymously, right? We say,
well, you know, he he got shot. What's
he got shot? He's dead. That's what we
we mean when we say that. speaking about
someone who's dead. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam didn't add to
this. And why do I mention this? Because
in Islamic law,
death,
death, homicide rather, we should say,
homicide, which is one human taking the
life of another. Homicide is three types
in the Islamic court. Okay? You have
right.
So you have
you have
homicide which is accidental homicide.
Right? Because in English in in American
judicial system, right, the word
homicide literally means a human being
taking the life of another human being.
And it could be accidental homicide. It
could be intentional homicide,
premeditated homicide, right? Murder is
only intentional. Person intended to
take the life of another. Sometimes they
call it manslaughter. So we have this
gradation in Islamic court. So we have
homicide which is accidental. So
accidental homicide. We have intentional
homicide and we have
intentional or we have unintentional
homicide. Unintentional homicide.
So what these three things they have
they make a difference in the ruling.
They make a difference in the ruling. We
have one who shoots another person with
a gun. We have one who's playing with a
gun and it goes off. We have another who
uses a taser on someone. These are three
different situations. They're not all
the same. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam didn't consider them all the
same. However, in this narration,
we see that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam is teaching us that if a person
uses a mostly lethal tool to take the
life of another, unless there are some
very strong evidences that this was an
this this was a horrible accident,
immediately this is considered to be
intentional intentional homicide,
murder. And if it is premeditated
murder, this person is is is executed no
matter what the situation.
Premeditated murder is always an an
execution. There is no we forgive him
even if the family forgives him because
premeditation and murder articulates
malice and articulates a person who is
out of control and needs to be protected
needs society to be protected from him.
So the point here is that the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam with regards to
intentions
we see even in the way that he speaks he
is using the tool and not
elaborating on the intention. If two
Muslims meet one another with the swords
with their swords drawn,
then the killer and his victim are both
in hell. Notice here he says the killer
and his victim. He doesn't say and they
both intended to kill each other.
Because now a Muslim judge would not
take into consideration a person's
intention.
Why? Because the sword is a lethal is a
lethal weapon. It's used to take life.
No one can come and say, "Well, I just
meant to cut him up a little bit. I just
meant to cut off an arm or a leg."
Right? And you know, you hear this from
people who are not acquainted with
violence. For instance, people will say,
"Well, you know, the the police, they
should shoot him in the leg, you know,
instead of shooting them in the chest or
something should shoot him in the leg."
It's a gun. It's designed to kill
anywhere you get shot on your body.
That's what it's for. This is a silly
proposition. We don't have any such
thing as shoot him in the leg or shoot
him in the arm in the movies. This
is silliness. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam judges both of
them in hell.
Both of them. The killer and his victim
in hell. We'll continue this tomorrow.
Inshallahhammed.
Alhamdulillah.